well in a blitzkrieg campaign last year
liberals across America got plastic
straws banned in many cities and
restricted in entire states life got a
little bit worse for normal people but
not bad enough so now liberals in
California of a new target no it's not
actually something there's too much of
like heroin or human feces on the
sidewalk those are everywhere but that's
totally cool human expression instead
they're going after hotel shampoo
bottles a problem you didn't know
existed a group of lawmakers in this
state want to ban those completely
anyone who breaks the law can be fined
500 bucks for every offense Timmy Bruce
is one of her she's an offender of this
would-be law but she has a radio show
host and president the independence
voice and she joins us tonight do you
feel safer now I feel weirdly safer that
you're the one in California and I'm out
here in New York so I'm weird look this
is a proposed bill it's it's it's stupid
you've got people of course they're
saying it's because of the plastic in
the ocean but here's the truth of the
matter a headline in Forbes last year
five Asian countries dumped more plastic
into oceans then everybody else combined
China Indonesia the Philippines Thailand
and Vietnam the United States is not the
problem Californians strangely enough
are not the problem and yet they ban the
straws they're banning the plastic bags
and now it's the little tiny shampoo
bottles that you can't have them in
hotels or in any kind of rental or in
the resorts because we're gonna save the
oceans the problem with this of course
is that people think they're doing
something to help the problem and
they're not but as you mentioned in
California you can relieve yourself on
the street you can smoke marijuana to
your heart's content but god help you
should you have one of those little imp
yueshen bottles of Listerine that now is
the problem so take a good whiff of
California air a Tucker because with the
poo on the street and with nobody being
able to shampoo it's gonna start
smelling pretty bad in the Golden State
this isn't a sand there's a reason they
call it the Golden State sadly but this
is an assault and cleanliness you're
totally right and I could of course
didn't connect the dots because I'm in
California and a little high being
honest but well you know
it's a assault on cleanliness well look
it the tiny bottles suggest also look
there's droughts all the time when you
get into that shower in the hotel the
tiny bottle says to you make it quick
you've got enough for maybe like a
quarters worth of shampoo and there's
linger don't linger in there this is a
brief visit they're saying you should
put in dispensers like in a spa well
then you're gonna spend an hour in the
shower using all the water and then of
course that will be a crime so I'm
waiting for the guy of unintended
consequence that's it everything they
touch ends up being making things worse
and in this case that will be the issue
as well trust me and I'm gonna go buy a
hundred of the little bottles when I
leave here and that's all I'm gonna use
in my own bag along with missing light
bulbs that's right out of my shower
Tammy Bruce great to see you thank you
for that thank you dear see you later